Over the past 5 decades nuclear power has
prevented the release of 50 gigatonnes of
carbon dioxide.
That’s equivalent to 2 years of total global
energy generation related emissions.
[REF][1]
Nuclear Power is the most powerful tool at
our disposal to stop human driven climate
change in its tracks, yet powerful industrial
countries like Germany have turned their back
on this technology.
Rapidly deactivating power plants prematurely.
Nuclear power, despite its clear climate change
fighting potential, carries inherent risks
that have hampered political will to invest
in the technology.
In order to thrive and help our planet overcome
its greatest challenge, nuclear Power needs
to evolve.
This is the Future of Nuclear power.
We can’t begin to address the solutions
of the future, without addressing the failures
of the past.
Many of the most notorious nuclear meltdowns
were caused by errors in coolant systems.
Take the three-mile island partial meltdown
incident of 1979.
The incident began with a mechanical failure
in the plant's cooling system.
It all started when the steam generator stopped
receiving water due to a faulty clogged filter.
The loss of water meant that the reactor's
energy didn't have anywhere to go, raising
the temperature of the reactor.
As the pressure rose due to water being boiled,
a relief valve opened.
[2][REF]
A valve designed to only open for 10 seconds,
but another fault resulted in the valve staying
open.
Allowing the precious coolant inside the reactor
to escape.
Pushing temperatures even higher.
As the core temperature continued to rise,
the reactor operators received conflicting
information from the control room.
The emergency water system that should have
provided extra water to the cores was blocked.
Two days earlier, the plant was closed due
to maintenance, and the valves for the emergency
coolant were closed.
Unfortunately, they were not reopened when
the reactor was restarted.
The operator should have noticed that these
valves were closed but for reasons unknown,
he didn't see the warning lights in his panel.
One leading theory is that his stomach blocked
his view of the control panel.
Even then, The NRC, the regulatory body governing
nuclear safety, Had a rule that if the emergency
coolant valves were closed, the reactor must
be shut down.
The Situation at Three Mile Island was in
clear violation of those rules.
While the meltdown was triggered by a mechanical
failure, the situation was worsened by human
error.
The Three Mile Island incident serves as a
reminder of the critical importance of both
robust mechanical safety systems and foolproof
controls in nuclear power plants.
It highlights the need for attention to detail
in design, where even minor aspects like the
positioning of alarms on control panels can
have far-reaching consequences, potentially
leading to catastrophic meltdowns.
To prevent such incidents, future nuclear
power plant designs must proactively address
these issues.
When the consequences of human error are nuclear
meltdowns, there is no room for human error.
[REF][3]
In Fukushima, an earthquake and its resulting
tsunami knocked out the plant's cooling systems.
The cooling systems in Fukushima depended
on a separate energy source.
The pumps that were needed to cool the reactors
lost power, resulting in a catastrophic meltdown.
The plant did have a backup system, which
also failed.
This need for external power to cool the reactors
was a key disadvantage of the design.
Fukushima also highlighted a weakness of current
nuclear reactors, the use of water as a coolant.
Liquid water is a great conductor of heat
and serves as a fantastic cooling agent.
However, when control is lost this water can
lead to a high-pressure steam explosion, spreading
radioactive materials across vast distances.
For this reason, many new reactor designs
seek to incorporate passive cooling systems,
which require no external power source, and
aim to replace water with safer cooling mediums.
Before discussing these future designs, there
is another large problem facing Nuclear Energy.
Its waste.
Light-water reactors operate in what is called
an open fuel cycle.
In this cycle, The uranium gets mined, processed,
enriched, used, and then stored.
Leaving us with barrels of radioactive waste
that governments have been struggling to deal
with.
In the US, there has been a plan to create
deep geological storage facilities 660 meters
below Yucca Mountain.
This has been the plan since the 1980s but
hasn't been put into action, so nuclear fuel
is still being stored in dangerous interim
storage facilities scattered around the country.
As is the case with most nuclear energy projects
it has faced delays and a lack of funding.
Obama, Trump, and Biden have all failed to
address this looming ecological threat.
Waste management issues have continually caused
political turmoil.
Shipments of nuclear waste from France to
Germany have been met with thousands of protestors,
a key driver of political pushback on the
development of nuclear energy.
So is there an engineering solution to this
logistical concern?
Of Course, adequate long-term storage is possible.
Sweden has approved large storage repositories
here in Frostmak. [4,5][REF][REF] Finland
has made similar arrangements to store its
Nuclear waste here.
[4,6][REF] [REF]This Finnish deep geological
repository is expected to come online within
a year.
Deep geological repositories are sophisticated
engineered systems that employ multiple layers
of protective barriers to isolate the spent
fuel from the surrounding environment.
[REF] [4]
What if we could make use of this nuclear
waste, rather than locking it away for centuries
like a supernatural Zelda villain.
Nuclear waste can be recycled.
During the early development of Nuclear power,
Uranium was thought to be a limited resource
so a lot of research was directed into creating
closed fuel cycles where the spent uranium
would be reprocessed and recycled.
But the assumption of limited uranium was
wrong.
Uranium is very common in the earth's crust.
It’s much cheaper to mine, enrich, and process
uranium than it is to recycle nuclear waste
into workable fuel.
Hence the adoption of an open fuel cycle.
This is the system currently operating on
most nuclear reactors with new waste piling
every minute.
Recycling spent nuclear fuel is just a matter
of separating unused uranium from the fission
products.
This process is also not new, it was developed
in the 1950s and the basic steps are still
used today in France and in Japan.
France for example, cools its nuclear waste
here.
For three years it sits there before moving
to the reprocessing steps.
[REF] [7]
With the added cost, and the potential of
extracting plutonium for nuclear weapons,
the Carter administration banned US recycling
facilities in 1977.
[REF] [7]
This recycled fuel can go back into regular
light water reactors, or it could go into
newer reactor designs.
Two common themes in new generation reactors
is passive cooling and higher thermal efficiencies
through high temperature coolants.
Light water reactors are limited to an operating
temperature of around 300 degrees celsius,
above this temperature the high pressure water
begins to boil.
Thermal efficiency is how much electrical
energy we can produce from thermal energy,
and in general, this efficiency gets better
with higher temperatures.
To increase efficiency, future nuclear reactors
can switch the coolant to something that can
handle higher temperatures.
In the early 2000s, the US Department of Energy
decided to create the Gen IV international
forum.
It was composed of the best scientists around
the world to direct policy decisions and funding
for new reactor designs.
They chose a total of 6 new reactor technologies
and coined them Generation IV reactors.
Instead of using water as a coolant, Gen IV
reactors can use gas, supercritical water,
molten salts, molten lead, or sodium to increase
the operating temperature of the reactor.
This increase in efficiency will result in
less nuclear waste per gigawatt generated,
but these designs also aim to increase passive
cooling capabilities and limit nuclear proliferation
risks.
One of the most interesting prospects is the
Molten salt reactor or MSR.
In these reactors, the coolant and the radioactive
fissile material are all combined.
The basic premise of these reactors was tested
and experimented with during the 1960s at
the Oak Ridge National Laboratory
In an MSR, the fuel consists of nuclear fuel,
such as uranium or thorium, dissolved in a
molten salt mixture.
The salts typically used are fluorides or
chlorides, which have high melting points
and good heat transfer properties.
The fuel salt circulates through the reactor
core, absorbing heat generated by nuclear
fission.
After it passes through the core, the fuel
salt transfers heat to a secondary salt coolant
loop.
The secondary salt, which does not contain
fissile material, absorbs the heat from the
fuel salt and carries it to a heat exchanger.
In the heat exchanger, the heat from the secondary
salt is transferred to a separate working
fluid, typically water, which then powers
a steam generator.
Since the coolant that they use does not need
to be at high pressure like the water-cooled
reactors in Fukushima, salt reactors also
are not at risk of high-temperature steam
explosions.
While light water reactors typically have
a thermal energy efficiency of around 30%,
molten salt reactors have been theorized to
achieve efficiencies between 40% to 45% [REF]
[4].
Molten Salt Reactors also have the potential
for inline fuel processing, which means that
while the reactor is operating, the fuel salt
can be continuously reprocessed to remove
fission products and add new fuel.
Meaning the machine can run continuously without
stopping for refueling.
At first glance, you'll notice that the system
needs not one, but two pumps.
However, these reactors can safely cool down
even when power is lost to these pumps.
The salts' chemical properties naturally inhibit
further nuclear fission as temperatures increase.
The exact mechanisms of this depend on the
salt composition, but generally, as the molten
salt gets hotter, it expands.
This expansion decreases the volume of fuel
in the core of the reactors, and therefore
decreases the rate of nuclear fission.
[Ref] [Ref][8,9]
Meaning, the hotter it gets, the less fission
occurs, helping prevent nuclear meltdown.
[REF][9]
A freeze plug is also located at the bottom
of the liquid salt pool.
The freeze plug is designed to melt at a particular
temperature.
In the event of an uncontrolled rise in temperature
the plug will melt and allow the fuel and
molten salt to passively drain into cooled
dump tanks.
[REF][9]
Molten Salt Reactors are some time away from
commercial readiness and that problem extends
to all other 4th generation reactors despite
significant support from proponents of these
technologies.
The 4th generation international forum originally
proposed that most of these technologies would
to be ready by 2020, but based on the fact
that the only footage available is from the
1960s, that has not come to fruition.
Lack of funding, and competition from low
cost solar and wind, has held back development
of these fourth generation technologies.
This problem is only going to continue until
Nuclear energy addresses its largest problem.
Cost.
Since 2003, MIT has been conducting studies
specifically aimed at guiding researchers
and policymakers towards a viable future for
nuclear energy.
In their latest report, they stated that the
utmost importance must be given to lowering
the cost of nuclear plants.[REF] [4].
And thus, the most promising ideas seek to
address these cost issues.
While deep geological repositories, uranium
reprocessing, and Gen IV reactors had the
brunt of the work done during the 1900s.
A new design concept started to emerge in
the early 2000s.
Small Modular Reactors, or SMRs for short.
The goal of this design is to miniaturize
reactors and convert them into small standardized
modules that can be fabricated in factories.
This standardization not only could decrease
costs but inherently increases their reliability
and safety as complexity is removed from the
manufacturing and assembly while decreasing
on-site construction costs.
Small modular reactors work in much the same
way as regular nuclear plants, but with smaller
individual reactors that can work in expandable
modules.
Gradually increasing the output of a power
plant with cheaper factory-made modules, rather
than building one large custom-designed nuclear
power plant with 1000 Megawatts of electricity
capacity.
[REF][10]
Making the reactors smaller also comes with
the big benefit of passive safety.
A smaller reactor has more surface area for
heat transfer to occur in proportion to the
volume of material that needs cooling.
Meaning natural convection cycles are sufficient
to cool the reactor.
As the coolant is heated, it rises due to
its lower density, establishing a natural
flow pattern that drives the cooling process.
SMRs are not defined as one type of nuclear
reactor or one design, rather, they are a
family of designs that takes advantage of
the miniaturization of the technology.
Because of this, no one SMR is like the other.
Some use Gen IV reactors, others use light
water reactors.
Currently, over 70 commercial small modular
reactors are being developed.
[REF][REF][11,12]
Nuscale may be the most promising of all these
companies.
Their most recent 77MW Module is around 20
m tall and 4.5 m in diameter.
[REF] [13] Each of these modules is lowered
into a water bath and set on top of seismic
isolators.
This makes sure that any earthquakes do not
affect the reactor.
[REF] [14] All of the components needed for
the nuclear reaction are fitted in one steel
containment vessel.
To create a larger plant, Multiple modules
are connected together.
If power to the reactor is lost, control rods
fall automatically in a gravity driven mechanism,
and the containment vessel seals its valves
to isolate itself.
The water from the core is boiled off as steam
but stays inside the containment vessel.
Transferring heat with the outside cooling
pool, the steam condenses and pools at the
bottom of the reactor vessel.
Creating a natural circulation of cooling
water inside the steel containment vessel.
Within seconds the energy and temperature
drop drastically and within a day the thermal
power drops by 90%.
Cooling off the last 10% over the course of
weeks.
And while this all sounds great, we are nowhere
near commercial deployment.
NuScale is by far the most ahead, but have
only managed to create a one-third scale model
of their power plant.
[15][REF]
Other countries like Russia, China, France,
and South Korea have also invested in creating
SMR technologies but have struggled to find
utility customers.
Without potential customers these startups
will always fail in a capitalist system.
Even Nuslace has been dropped by some utility
clients as their prices seem to have exceeded
expectations.
[REF] [16]
This poses a massive challenge to companies
that rely on large-scale standardized factories
to achieve their key market advantage.
To build the factory they need customers,
but they can’t get customers without the
factory.
Thousands of reactors will need to be built
before economies of scale can kick in, and
in reality, the exact reason traditional nuclear
reactors produce so much electricity is to
benefit from the economies of scale.
Building a 1000 MW reactor reduces the cost
per megawatt, and that’s THE most important
metric in the electricity market.
That’s how you get grid operators to buy
your electricity, by making it cheaper.
NuScales’ original price point was 55$/
MWh.
However, due to inflation, rising steel costs,
development issues, and many delays the costs
are now estimated at 100$/ MWh. [17,18][REF][REF]
In comparison, onshore wind and solar can
be as cheap as 30$/MWh [19].
[REF].
With the threat of climate change looming
over us, we need to ask ourselves.
Can we rely on a capitalist system to fix
a problem driven by capitalism?
There is a distinct possibility that these
technologies will never succeed without government
funding.
Energy generation is the foundation of every
major world economy, and it is in countries
best interest to invest in these technologies
. Nuclear energy provides energy security.
The US is not alone in trying to develop the
technology.
China has embarked on the construction of
a functional small modular reactor (SMR) project
here.
However, similar to many nuclear ventures,
costs have significantly escalated, with the
SMR reportedly being twice as expensive, in
terms of cost per kilowatt hour, compared
to a traditional large-scale nuclear plant.
[REF][20]
Canada has formulated a 2020 SMR action plan
to help bring down cost, and have invested
millions of dollars into SMR start ups.
[REF] [REF] [21,22]
Developing these technologies will need vastly
more money than this, but it’s a step in
the right direction.
Wind and solar are game changing technologies
that we could only have dreamed of being as
cheap as they are today 2 decades ago, but
we need every tool at our disposal to fight
climate change.
Not just to decarbonize our energy generation,
but to start fighting the effects of climate
change ,population growth and global industrialization.
From increasing demand for air conditioning,
water scarcity driving the need for energy
intensive water desalination, to last ditch
efforts to reverse climate change with carbon
capture.
Energy is the cause and solution to our problems.
The transition from fossil fuels, in my opinion,
is the most pressing issue facing humanity.
This is an all hands on deck problem.
We need our best minds working on it, and
I see it as part of my responsibility with
a platform as large as mine to inspire the
next generation of engineers to work on the
solutions.
Where I try to inspire, I see Brilliant as
the perfect partner for follow through.
For education.
The courses on Brilliant are perfect for getting
you prepared for engineering college, or for
simply advancing your current career.
From advanced mathematics courses to computer
science.
They even have courses on the very foundation
of energy generation, electricity and magnetism.
Brilliant uses interactive courses that test
your knowledge along the way.
A platform designed to teach you difficult
subjects in the most efficient way possible.
Using visual interactive examples, and they
don’t impede your progress when you struggle.
If you can’t figure out an answer, you can
open an in depth explanation and move onto
the next section.
These are likely the most universally useful
courses to present and future engineers, but
there are plenty of other courses on Brilliant.
AI, data science, neural networks and more.
You can get access to that course right now,
and all of Brilliant's other curated interactive
courses, by clicking the link in the description
and on screen now.
You can get started for free for 30 days,
and the first 500 people to do so will get
20% off Brilliant's annual premium subscription